um hello there to you Alex claims by the
Russians that they have taken solidar of
course important in that symbolic aim of
theirs to take back much what's
happening
well we've been hearing for a number of
days now claims by Russian forces the
Wagner mercenary Group which is doing
much of the fighting in solidar it's
claimed that it had taken it uh it's
taken the town some days ago but now
we're hearing that confirmation
according to the Russians from the
ministry of Defense now the day before
yesterday the Kremlin said it would wait
before it went with that announcement
and now it has now earlier today the
ukrainians were saying that it was still
hotly contested after a very heavy night
of fighting we were there yesterday
we're in a place called sloviansk it's
about 60 70 kilometers away and it
appeared yesterday to us that certainly
the ukrainians had been pushed out of
most or if not all of the town they were
certainly still very very heavy fighting
going on uh huge amounts of artillery
going on we heard a lot of small arms
fighting Small Arms fire as well which
suggests that this close quarter combat
now it may very well have been yesterday
that there were a number of Ukrainian
troops still trapped inside the town and
kind of fighting to the last man we know
that there have been very serious uh
very heavy casualties on both sides but
certainly it looked as though Russian
forces were moving through most of the
town it's a battle that's been going on
for a number of months with the you know
this this latest offensive for it
probably over the last couple of weeks
now the reason that the Russians wanted
it so important to them is that they
believe that it will give them a
tactical advantage to take the nearby
town of Bak moots which they've been
fighting for now for a very very long
time at a great expense in terms of
blood and materiel it's debatable
whether that will happen they think they
can now cut off the communications and
the logistics that the ukrainians need
to support their operations in back moot
that is denied by the ukrainians but if
this is verified and confirmed by the
Ukrainian solidar will really be the
first victory that Russia has had on the
battlefield for for many many many
months after a number of military
setbacks